elena ahora bidegáin viene en busca de
verdad su padre carlos horacio urán un
magistrado de 43 años murió
misteriosamente en noviembre de 1985
cuando el ejercito retomaba el palacio
de justicia después de que la guerrilla
del m-19 se tomara el lugar ahora se
sabe que civiles fueron torturados y
desaparecidos en el proceso luego de que
vídeos mostraron que habían salido del
recinto con vida
elena quiere que se reconozca el caso de
su padre como un crimen de estado que
por 36 años se ha intentado esconder yo
quedé completamente silenciada
casi a la par de la sociedad colombiana
que acató el pacto de silencio impuesto
desde el poder hegemónico y fue hace no
muchos años que yo me di cuenta que
tenía que romper ese silencio y tenía
que empezar a contar lo que había
sucedido que eso no era culpa mía no
tenía que sentir vergüenza sino que la
vergüenza lo tenían que sentir los
perpetradores a modo de respuestas se
inauguró la muestra huellas de
desaparición está reconstruye mediante
realidad virtual y 3d el caso del
palacio de justicia tras una
recopilación exhaustiva de vídeos
declaraciones y documentos judiciales
desclasificados busca determinar cómo
las víctimas habrían sido seleccionadas
torturadas desaparecidas o asesinadas y
trasladadas nuevamente al palacio
simulando una muerte en combate es un
adelanto del informe final que
presentará la comisión de la verdad en
junio de 2022 yo creo que eso por lo
menos contribuye a que nos veamos como
en un espejo frente a esta exposición y
que por lo menos nos ayuda a reflexionar
para ver si podemos salir de esta
persistencia del conflicto armado otros
casos emblemáticos como el de
desaparición de campesinos en urabá y el
desplazamiento sistemático del pueblo
nunca que en la amazonía colombiana
también hacen parte de esta exhibición
realizada por la agencia de
investigación británica forensic
arquitectura
mediante la reconstrucción
arquitectónica comienzas a ver
relaciones la forma en que se operó
existe arquitectura y los arquitectos
son acerca de
una nutrida máquina de represión
como muchos otros elena guarda la
esperanza de que estas investigaciones
saquen a la luz la verdad de lo ocurrido
y que la justicia esclarezca este y
otros crímenes de estado